en este distrito al noroccidente kiev
recientemente impactó un misil ruso que
tuvo como objetivo la torre de
televisión en un bloqueo cercano los
habitantes de este distrito están
armados controlando quién sale y quién
entra estaban aquí cuando cayó el misil
a sólo 300 metros de distancia estamos
aquí para proteger nuestra ciudad
nuestro país nuestras familias viven
aquí todos sabemos los riesgos que
corremos un hombre en patineta eléctrica
con un kalashnikov al cuello llega el
bloqueo
es así como patrulla la zona si tengo
que ser rápido para dirigir a la gente
llevó a la gente los refugios cuando
suenan las sirenas
en este momento las sirenas antiaéreas
comienzan a sonar
pongo yevgueni yurjevic dirige el camino
hacia el refugio más cercano
en el sótano de un edificio de
apartamentos una mujer y su hijo de un
año se han refugiado desde el comienzo
de la invasión
por supuesto que estamos asustados con
estas sirenas sonando constantemente
mira lo que están haciendo los rusos qué
puedo decir
cuando las sirenas dejan de sonar y es
quien reanuda su patrulla hacia otro
bloqueo en el distrito los rusos están
acabados
una caja llena de cócteles mólotov
hechos por los habitantes
menciona a los niños todo el mundo está
colaborando
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa a
ucrania todo el mundo se ha comprometido
a ayudar de cualquier manera en este
caso construyen un refugio contra la
lluvia este vecino ofreció
espontáneamente sus servicios seguido
rápidamente por otro
las explosiones en la distancia no les
disuaden de su misión cinco minutos más
tarde algunos hombres todos de la zona
ayudan a construir el mejor refugio
posible